old people why is everyone all of a
sudden that's right I'm sure everyone's
seen this already old PewDiePie why
these peopIe look old
it's the face app they're back at it
again I wanted to actually try it out
let's try out a beautiful photo of
myself it's so awkward gorgeous I feel
like I'm the only one that bought this
app maybe this will be interesting
okay here we go okay I'm so excited
first okay wait you can do so much
because I have the full version so I can
see full beard how does that look like
okay
five thousand likes and little girl back
my beard there you go there it is you
know what let's just start what people
want to see people want to see the h1
how does pretty pie look when he's old
here we go I'm at the thing is the shell
brings my family we don't get gray hair
at least not my dad
or I never saw my granddad with gray
hair either
luckily I'll get to keep my right blonde
hair but my god it doesn't look good
does it
oh let's add makeup maybe that will save
it yeah can I save this I'll just save
it like that okay what happens if I take
this one and then I turn myself instead
of old I'll turn myself young oh my god
I look like James Charles head please
double old oh god oh god can I do it
again how many times can you old defy
yourself one more time that looks pretty
good
hey hey brows it's me Peter Pan welcome
to minecraft episode 50 hundred thousand
million when I said minecraft forever
series I meant it brows female okay turn
me into your baby oh heck yeah oh
grandma beautified is looking hella sexy
whoa whoa whoa
okay okay
alright let's just do another photo
we'll do a blank face
Smiley's always so creepy to me cuz it's
just a cheap and nothing else what do
you guys think okay they have upset as
well what what happens if you take smile
and add smile does it just double smile
triple smile it is
smile for the camera please here we go
okay how does he work I don't get it
gender swap here we go oh my god I look
like my mom when she was younger this is
so creeping me out dude why do I have a
beard oh what's that
get out we also have hairstyles I'm
always thinking what kind of hair I
should get Hey look I'm Justin Bieber
how do I look bold then I mean I'll take
it
let's do bold and then add a beard cuz
that's that's the look I truly whine
luckily my family we all get to keep our
hair maybe I'm an exception but you know
if it does it's not that bad okay let's
try this with some other people okay
let's do Marty's yeah Marcia I'm sorry
old well it's not bad it's a lot better
than me that's for sure oh my god
science was not created for this I keep
telling you what if we make her young
again oh my god oh my god that's pretty
good Dan
I mean she looked worse but here's what
I really want to see might see as a dude
no no I'll take this guy how do I look
like with a beard maybe maybe that will
make it better okay yeah that's better
yeah let's see if we can salvage this
give him a smile with the right filters
anyone can look good
Trisha Paytas everyone oh yeah yeah yeah
it's starting to look better change the
hair color we give myself a blonde we're
gonna fix this it's gonna be okay oh
yeah oh yeah I like that
maybe glasses to cover up some of those
wrinkles no makeup necessary hello my
name is PewDiePie and H is just a number
Jesus Christ all right let's look at my
man Jack first of all is he free Keable
as a female the real question I mean
absolutely not
is he free Keable as oh wow oh
absolutely
is he free Keable as it no wait oh it
looks like Zayn we all know him but what
about mrs. beast what about grandpa
beast
[Laughter]
what about beardy Beast not bad look
something to consider mr. beast are my
friends free Keable let's have a look
[Music]
it's mortgage mom damn no difference
what do we take Ken female Ken and turn
into back to male ooh oh that's weird
oh god it's so weird it looks so real
but so fake at the same time like he
makes no sense alright I gotta try Brad
Brad has been posting a lot of a concern
of allah mount of selfies lately Brad
are you looking for a new girlfriend
what is happening okay here we are
Brad looking good by the way very nice
but how does he look like when he's old
why is it funny every time the same
thing wrinkles and gray hair ha ha what
about Brad young Sam it looks like
Brandis making videos again oh wait he
is checking out Boyd shout out but is he
free cable
I don't think Brad looks like Bhima Brad
it looks like he he's about to tell me
why that word is insensitive right looks
like the kind of person that will tap
you on your shoulder and a pub and be
like can you guys keep it down I'm
trying to discuss books with myself oh
that's right I wanted to try if you can
do it on a burger
what and it shows a cat they knew all
right let's nuke this thing oh hey guys
we're gonna bring back happy wheels for
the hundredth time we're bringing back
every with it's gonna be epic brows at a
quadrillion oh my god at a quadrillion
likes hey let's do one more just one
more what could possibly wear I have my
lips gone why is my eyes sinking into
themselves now can these be salvageable
that is the question young make me young
[Laughter]
what is this
who is that oh wow yeah that looks good
again let's save that and let's make it
young again oh wow that looks so good
Wow I think I think I think it's rude
well maybe actually if we maybe turn
into female in mind
Mike's correct itself we're gonna blow
up their servers now there's too much
too much oh I don't even know what I'm
doing anymore hey also we have 30% off
now if you entered the code PewDiePie if
you want to check out by the shaker and
my favorite flavors check out a link in
description and recover your pot 30%
that's
why don't you do like a really bad photo
it really looks like my old beer -
that's so freaky how do I look like we
belong here not good not good everyone
okay cool
how about black I was wondering not good
okay
actually you know what I want to try and
make myself find like my the best style
maybe like a little bit more beard yeah
yeah that looks good
well tin up the hair just a little bit
just a little bit I mean it looks bad I
don't know why I did it
okay it's just to change something hair
style have Zagon brows it's 2014 period
back how do I look like with long hair
oh yeah long hair it is okay just give
me the makeup we want something subtle
and classy
I want James Charles to approve yeah
this is not what I'm looking for okay
Matt maybe oh my gosh and then finally
just a little touch of youngness little
fountain of beauty
let's get real you like that you let
this creature call you daddy don't lie
for me oh my god how can I forget I have
to why should I do
female but it's already female this
makes no sense oh this weird that he
looks better without the filter this
week this fix a smile oh yeah a little
Fountain of Youth and kind of make you
better Brad I'm sorry I'm curious like
what happens if you take an actual baby
and make the baby old does our old okay
what happened
wait what's that movie Benjamin Button
all right that's me playing around with
face up I hope you had fun with me it
was it was fun for me
minecraft tomorrow I promise specially I
can be enjoyed subscribe we're almost at
a hundred million subscribers and at a
hundred million something epic will
happen
check out merch very epic and thanks for
watching bye bye what you never played
super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet
okay I'll cut you a deal the game is
available for free and that's a great
price
[Music]